what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or bro and today i will be
explaining every member of team natsu
from fairytale and their awesome powers
the fairytale guild has a lot of amazing
characters with some pretty insane
powers and abilities within its ranks so
today we're going to take a deep dive
into the members of team natsu not only
will we be going over the main members
of the team but we will also look into
the temporary members of the team too
now if you do enjoy this fairy tale
video you know what to do channel the
dragon slayer within and obliterate that
like button if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also follow
anime or raw on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and if you really want to
feel free to follow me as well at 414
anime underscore of course this video
will contain fairy tale spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned starting off with none other
than natsu natsu is an expert when it
comes to his ability dragon slayer magic
dragon slayer magic is a lost type of
magic in which the user can transform
their physical body or just specific
parts of their body into a dragon
natsu's magic is that of flames these
flames can come from any part of his
body and they are extremely strong said
to be equivalent to that of a dragon's
fire and they can even burn through
metal now as one of the five dragon
slayers natsu can consume his element
which in his case is of course fire now
by doing this he can replenish his own
energy reserves but he can't consume the
flames that he himself has created this
makes him immune to most types of flames
nazi's flames can also increase in
temperature based on his own emotional
state the more enraged our boy gets the
hotter his flames do too this was also
called the flame of emotion his
signature move is his fire dragon's roar
in which natsu gathers and releases a
huge amount of flames from his mouth
completely incinerating his target natsu
has mastered this spell so well that he
can create a continuous stream of fire
creating a wall of fire across the
entire battlefield his other basic
spells that are worth mentioning include
fire dragon's claw natsu ignites flames
that cover his feet and this not only
increases the power of his kicks but it
also propels him forward in quick bursts
just like fire dragon's claw fire
dragon's iron fist works in the same way
except natsu ignites his fists in flames
which he will then use to deliver some
devastating punches to his opponents now
the list really goes on here with other
basic attacks such as fire dragon's wing
attack fire dragon sword horn and fire
dragon's grip strike nazi certainly
isn't short on move sets that's for sure
the lad is also not sure on advanced
attacks crimson lotus fire dragon's fist
is a series of rapid punches that cause
explosions of fire due to his fists
being ablaze crimson lotus exploding
flame blade sees not to swing his arms
in a circular motion that creates a
barrage of flames upon his target that
have insane destructive power he also
has crimson lotus fenix blade where
natsu ignites his entire body in flames
devastating his enemy with a powerful
uppercut that sends them into the air
natsu then pursues them and finishes
them with an explosive headbutt now
fairy tale really does have a nice
collection of girls at times you feel
spoiled for choice but next we are
moving on to my personal best girl of
the series
lucy heartfelia
lucy uses celestial spirit magic this is
a type of spatial magic in which the
user can summon celestial spirits by
opening their gates using celestial
spirit gate keys the keys themselves are
split into two different classes
extremely rare gold keys that can open
the gates to the ecliptic zodiacs each
of these are related to a particular
astrological sign and then there's the
more common silver keys which can be
simply found and bought in shops now out
of the 12 gold keys that exist lucy our
girl owns 10 of them whilst also owning
an additional five silver keys so once a
celestial spirit mage receives a key and
opens the celestial gate for the first
time they must set up a contract with
said spirit the contract involves things
such as asking what days it can be
summoned now each of the celestial
spirits have differing power levels but
as well as that they also tend to be
better suited for different tasks not
always related to that of combat may i
add the key examples here
get it
i know okay so the key examples would be
aquarius who is a spirit that can
manipulate water being more useful in
dealing with multiple enemies at once
due to the powerful waves that she
creates on the other hand taurus is a
spirit who has an insane level of power
and strength thus he is better suited to
melee conditions our girl lucy has the
advanced ability of being able to call
upon and summon multiple celestial
spirits at once which gives her better
flexibility when it comes to her
strategy and battle as she can combine
the strengths and weaknesses of the
different spirits now in doing this it
does require a large amount of magical
power to keep multiple celestials
summoned which was something she did
struggle with initially but has gained
greater control over she can also force
the gate of a celestial spirit to close
against their will which sends them
straight back to the celestial spirit
world for me one of the coolest
celestial spells lucy has is called star
dress she can absorb the power of a
celestial spirit into her own body by
placing the key of said spirit to her
chest that is one lucky key am i right
damn now a portion of the spirit's
magical power is hers to use it is
visually represented by a change in
lucy's attire to match the spirit she
has selected last power to mention for
lucy has to be yorano metria lucy
recites the incantation and in doing so
the 88 constellations of the sky fall
from the sky as spheres giving lucy
their power she then aims at her target
and releases all of that gathered energy
in one insane attack it's freaking
gnarly man okay moving on to happy and
exceed from the kingdom of extalia
exceeds are basically a race of cat-like
beings some are super cute and others
are definitely not so now happy's main
and pretty much only ability is called
era in which he gains angelic-like wings
with these wings happy is able to fly
carrying objects or a single person for
a limited portion of time using his
magic power happy can fly quickly and
dodge enemy attacks or attack the enemy
himself flying at his max speed happy
drives forward towards his target and
then delivers an almighty strike with
his own head of course the downside to
happy's max speed is that it is based on
using his magic power to reach said
speeds meaning that if he does use this
it is at the cost of a rapid decrease of
his own magic power happy did also learn
basic spells when it comes to
transformation magic however he yeah he
really isn't great at this
his failed attempt led to his only
transformation being a really really
monstrous copy of lucy that um yeah she
herself had called nothing short of of
creepy it wasn't awesome next up we've
got another of fairy tales best girls
none other than the s-class mage as a
scarlet erza is an absolute powerhouse
and a master when it comes to combat her
signature form of magic and one she has
almost complete mastery of is called
requip requip is a spatial type magic
that allows her to swap weapons armor
and clothes at will urza is incredibly
fast when using this magic and is also
the only sword mage capable of using
reequip to the extent that she can
re-equip her armor and weapons during
combat erza's form of requip is called
the knight this allows her to store
weapons and armor in pocket dimensions
that she can pull from and summon during
battle urza is so well trained at using
this that she can pull up and project a
holographic screen displaying her
inventory the knight requip gives erza a
very high level of offense defense
flexibility and most importantly variety
whilst in battle erza herself is said to
have over 100 armor sets some of which
have resistance to you know elements and
other work well in certain situations
she can of course combine these two
dependent on her current situation heart
crew's armor is the one we see her in
the most she also has flame empress
armor that is resistant to fire
lightning empress armor which is
resistant to lightning and sea empress
armor which of course is resistant to
water she also has the very impressive
looking heaven's wheel armor which gives
irza the ability to fly and then there
is my personal favorite seduction armor
which uh
well you don't need me to explain
because uh culture of course you get it
right now to go with requip erza is an
extremely talented swordswoman and is
just as talented at using sword magic
sword magic allows urza to perform an
array of magical attacks that she will
often combine with a specific type of
armor her insane strength and skill
using her requip and sword magic has
made erza very well known throughout the
kingdom enough so that she had earned
the title to tania and if you want to be
the best erza is most definitely the
person to be but good luck with that
moving on to mr cool himself the
shirtless wonder that is gray fullbuster
gray was trained from a young age to use
ice make magic ice make magic is a
caster type magic in the form of
moulding magic in which the user can
create the element of ice and then mold
and shape that ice into pretty much
anything they want including weapons
what they make from the eyes can be used
for a number of things be it offensive
like grey's ice make lance defensive as
we see in his ice make wall or well
anything really ice make magic users can
freeze and reshape water uses magic as
we saw grey do with juvia the user can
do things from completely changing their
surroundings to that of ice to using ice
as a sort of wound dressing that it can
halt bleeding as well as reduce the
swelling from an injury all in all it's
an impressive and very versatile type of
magic now there are two types of ice
make magic the first is called static
ice make which is the creation of
objects and the changing of the
environment around the user the second
type is called dynamic ice make which
focuses on the creation of ice
sculptures dynamic ice make is said to
be the quicker to cast but static ice
make is going to be the most versatile
gray has been practicing this magic for
years and is extremely adept at it so it
should be to no surprise that grey
himself is resistant to cold as well as
to ice and snow based attacks next up
we've got wendy marvel a young female
skydragon slayer formerly of the kate
shelter guild now part of the fairy tale
guild and of team natsu wendy is a
dragon slayer and has the same type of
magic as natsu but you know whereas he
is a fire dragon slayer wendy is of
course a skydragon slayer meaning her
powers are based around the element of
air wendy is more of a supporter type as
she has healing magic her ability to
heal is so great that she can help
others recover from the most intensive
injuries even those caused by a dragon
wendy can manipulate the air to do
things from poison withdrawal from a
person who is infected to pretty much
reviving someone who is on the brink of
death but our girl isn't just about that
healing life as she can also perform
some pretty amazing supporter spells
that help buff the strength and speed of
both herself and others in her party not
only that but wendy can go on the
offensive herself too with sky dragons
raw now this works exactly like natsu's
fire dragon's raw except wendy shoots a
hurricane-like blast straight at her
target where wendy's differs is that she
can combine skydragon's raw with cure
combining her attack and healing powers
she used this to cure the memory block
placed on eregor rendering him unable to
continue in the battle the final
permanent member of team natsu is carla
carla is wendy's companion and an exceed
just like happy except carla is the
daughter of queen chigotay the current
ruler of the exceeds as an exceed she
has the same error ability as happy in
which she can sprout wings giving her
the ability of flight that speeds are
all determined by her magic power what i
mean by that is the same as happy so the
more magic power that is used the faster
she will be able to fly the faster she
flies the quicker it will drain her
magic power you get this right you get
this now carla can also use transform
magic but is much better at this than
happy after just one year of training
carla can transform into a human girl
that matches wendy's age in this form
she does keep her tail and cat ears but
the key difference is that carla's magic
is increased by a bit meaning her
precognition ability also gains a boost
precognition you say let me explain as
the daughter of the queen of exceeds
carla inherited her mother's ability to
predict where and when something will
happen it's important to note here that
carla and her mother are the only
exceeds within the entire race to have
this ability okay on to the temporary
members of team natsu starting with
elfman stross elfman's magic is takeover
takeover is an advanced caster type
magic that allows the user to take over
the power abilities and appearance of
other beings and use them for their own
this often gives the caster a boost in
strength power and speed but the user
can also gain a new skill such as flight
or breathing underwater as an example
the downside to this ability is that
they can only take over the things that
they truly know now there are currently
only five different types of takeover
and elf man's is called beast soul beast
soul allows elfman to seal the power of
monsters gaining the beast's powers
abilities and appearance where elfman
differs is in his partial takeover
ability in which unlike his sisters
instead of the full body takeover he
could only initially manage to change
his right arm the partial takeover often
made elfmanville great levels of
discomfort but it ended up benefiting
him as the partial takeover was his own
unique ability that became pretty
distinguished moving on we have warren
rocco a mage of the fairy tale guild and
another temporary member of team natsu
warren's ability was that of telepathy
telepathy is a caster type magic that
allows its caster to communicate through
thoughts warren can talk with other
people through their thoughts over long
distances as well as simply just hearing
others thoughts like all magic the more
ability and magic power that you have
the greater your ability now in terms of
telepathy the more magic power that you
have the more people you can connect
with all at once another handy aspect of
this ability is that everyone who is
connected at once can communicate with
each other using warren as some sort of
uh wi-fi hotspot if you will as for
warren he has a range of about five
kilometers more than that and he will
struggle he has also been seen to
struggle if too many people are trying
to talk at once and i could say we've
all been there without this ability
right now he also struggles if someone
is screaming which
again is relatable other than it being
an amazing magic for team use it's also
pretty handy for combat as warren is
able to hear his opponent's thoughts and
is thus able to predict their movements
okay time for some more noise as we move
on to imitate she was a temporary member
of team natsu when she used her
transformation powers combined with her
very deceptive nature to claim to be
michelle lobster a distant relative and
the half-sister of lucy heartfelia
imitation actually turns out not to be
michelle lobster but an animated form of
a doll lucy used to play with during her
childhood so in terms of powers she has
the obvious transformation magic
transformation magic is again a caster
type magic where the user is able to
completely change their appearance basic
forms of this magic is relatively easy
for pretty much any mage to use but
higher level mages such as imitation and
mirror jane had to get under the best
girl in there of course again
culture they can perform this magic and
all of its levels with great ease
transformation isn't the only magic she
can use but plant magic too another
caster type magic plant magic gives the
caster the power to create and
manipulate plants imitate can use plant
magic in combat as a form of attack
where she can produce many thorned vines
that will wrap around her targets and
target their vital points she can also
use plant magic for defense as she can
create a flower shield to block incoming
attacks to finish off her powers and
abilities it is worth touching on the
pros of her being a doll now because
imitation is a doll she has an immunity
to pain due to her doll-like nature she
boasts that it is impossible for her to
lose in combat to add to her claim even
further she is almost indestructible due
to the fact that she can mend broken
bones and muscles even neck injuries
won't finish her off imitation might be
a doll but she doesn't play around
10 out of 10 dad joke right final
temporary member of team natsu is messed
grider mest was a former member of the
magic council and is now a member of the
fairy tale guild his power is that of
memory control a caster type magic that
allows mess to add his existence to
another person's memory where he can
manipulate them delete memories and even
completely rewrite them as you can
imagine this magic is extremely powerful
in its own right but it does work like
that of a charm if the person affected
works out that their memories are being
manipulated by messed the effect of the
magic will wear off and the target
returns to their normal state now an
interesting thing to note about the
memory control magic is that mess can
use this on himself to modify his own
memories not only that but mess can also
relay his own memories to a person
whenever he chooses now as well as this
pretty op power mest also has
teleportation magic which is a spatial
type magic which allows him to teleport
and cover very large distances in the
blink of an eye this can be used in two
situations very effectively the obvious
being able to travel in a fast and
efficient manner goku style yeah boy but
it's also a very effective maneuver to
have in combat to either dodge incoming
attacks or to put yourself in a position
that allows you to deliver the final
devastating blow and that is it every
member of team natsu's powers and
abilities explained make sure to let us
know in the comments section below who
your favorite member of the team is no
scratch that more importantly who is
best girl at fairy tale i'm i'm really
i'm honestly i'm brought here just to
spread cultures to the channel as i did
with the dragon made video which is link
in the description who who is best girl
for you do you agree with my choice in
lucy or does your heart lie with another
let us know if you enjoyed this video
and you'd like to see more fairy tale
videos on the channel make sure to let
the guys know by smashing that like
button if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit the
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
anime or broad videos and of course you
can follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar and now i want to give a
big thank you to the anime or raw
patreons that make videos like this one
possible a special shout out to alpha
sigma an absolute mad lad and a disciple
of lord twego himself and of course are
the one-tier patrons the ones that stand
above all other clans that's in grata
pate heifer al-jazal hinokami and water
the toasted chi the spike 8227 dylan
isadore spidey life tennelle tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist and monkey d
quilly and finally a big thank you to
our pro hero tier patreons that include
the one and only gilgamesh the redhead
raven angel cruz raythan de aura very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks joanne
garcia ted no ted fatboy games corey
mcgowan and soul rise slice and dice if
you enjoy our videos here at anime or
consider checking out our patreon link
is in the description below anyone that
supports the anime or raw patreon for as
little as a single dollar has full
access to our patreon only member
discord and your name will appear at the
end of these videos just like the rest
of these absolute legends and again
thank you so much for watching we can't
wait to see you in the next one until
next time peace
[Music]
[Music]
you